For Darkseid!
Lex luthor fried the circuits bringing
his creature to life there's not enough
charge to wake the box
Welcome back everyone it's Charlie this
is going to be my new Justice League video
Zack Snyder was making a bunch of big
announcements about the dark side
character and the deleted scenes that
he'd be putting back into the movie so
we'll break it down if you're new to the
channel be sure to subscribe to get all
the videos we're doing an Amazon
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and let me know what you
want them to do wit dark side in the
Snyder cut-in apparently Zack Snyder was
also hyping up more Martian Manhunter so
I'll explain Martian Manhunter during
the video too because he was in Zack
Snyder's version of the story so just
going down the list starting with number
5 you all probably saw Zack Snyder
posting a lot recently about Darkseid on
his Twitter Darkseid is coming to HBO
max a couple of the official AT&T
Twitter accounts we're also talking
about Darkseid too and a lot of sites that
has been reporting on Darkseid since
they made the official Schneider cut
announcement last week I did a video
last week about a lot of the deleted
storylines and deleted scenes that they
were adding back into the Justice League
Snyder cut there's obviously that
deleted scene in the trailer that I
attached to the beginning of this that's
basically cyborg seeing dark side when
he plugs into the mother box for the
first time when they're trying to use it
to bring back Superman it was going to go
down a little bit differently during the
version that Zack Snyder was going to do
this is a sort of combination of the
theatrical cut in that version of that
deleted scene cyborg has a vision of him
destroying the earth but one of the
biggest things that got cut in the
theatrical version were all of Darkseid
scenes there were multiple dark side
scenes apparently in a little while
after the theatrical release Zack Snyder
came out it did a panel talking about
his alternate storyline all the things
that he had planned on doing with the
character Kevin Smith also separately
talked on his podcast about the original
Justice League storyline when it was
supposed to be three movies then after
Batman V Superman came out and the
studio started to panic they changed it
into two movies that were supposed to be
to Justice League movies then finally by
the end of things it turned into the one
movie that we all saw in theaters the
vast majority of the really big Darkseid
stuff was going to take place in Justice
League 2 in Justice League 3 so this is
basically just Zack Snyder confirming
what we all assumed Darkseid is coming
back into the Justice League Snyder cut
in a number of places so for the actor
who played Darkseid in Zack Snyder's
version
or should we say who will play Darkseid
in the new cut is named Ray Porter it
was a voiceover role he just did an
interview just this past week with light
cast talking about the original dark
side scenes he did and how he tried to
make him feel as otherworldly as
possible while still being clear enough
that you could actually sit in the
theater and understand what he was
saying best example of stuff like that
is the famous Tom Hardy Bane redub the
Christopher Nolan had to do on the Dark
Knight Rises because as much as people
made fun of the Bane voice in the
theatrical cut even Christopher Nolan
does a funny Tom Hardy Bane voice but
when they recorded all of Tom Hardy's
dialogue the first time it sounded even
more confusing and weird there's an
original teaser trailer for The Dark
Knight Rises where you can actually hear
what the original version of his voice
sounds like before they changed it by
the time they get to the last trailer
for the movie they'd already changed
everything but it was super muddy you
could barely understand what he was
saying so during post-production they
went in and remastered and re-released
dialogue just so people could understand
what Bane was saying during the movie
they didn't really have that problem
with Justice League with Darkseid or
even with Steppenwolf the actor that
they got to do the voice for Steppenwolf
was actually Ciaran Hinds if you
couldn't tell who it was most of the
stuff they wound up changing for
Steppenwolf and Darksiders obviously
they deleted all the Darkseid scenes and
then they changed the story line for
Steppenwolf and they just changed the
way he looked with special effects
there was a deleted scene from Batman V
Superman where Lex Luthor makes it into
the Kryptonian ship and he gets a
message from the ship's AI telling him
about Darkseid the mother boxes and
Steppenwolf this is actually what
Steppenwolf looked like in the Schneider
cut at least originally what he was
supposed to look like the reason why
they changed that to this theatrical
version is this because they felt like
this was more appealing to general
audiences but because a lot of the money
that they're giving Zack Snyder is to
finish special effects and changed
things with special effects maybe
they'll wind up changing Steppenwolf
back to the original version of
Steppenwolf but three the first really
big Darkseid change and deleted scenes
Zack Snyder are hyping up with all of
his tweets start with a huge flashback
scene of the war the original plan was
for this to be a really big Darkseid war
on earth fighting all these people not
Steppenwolf that's what this scene is
him standing in front of all those
combined armies of Amazon's Atlanteans
and humans in the theater
cut the flashback scene is only a couple
minutes long the version that Zack
Snyder shot was way way longer like
think of more like a short film taking
place inside the movie what was supposed
to be happening here at least in the
Snyder cut is that he was coming to
earth to conquer and to use the forest
resources he kind of saw a version of
that during Justice League Apocalypse
war which also talked about during this
video too the armies of earth come
together to fight him off you have all
the Greek gods who are still alive at
this point in history you have all the
original Atlanteans before Atlantis sank
into the ocean so this is meant to be
their version of King at land they went
up recasting him for the Aquaman movie
but it's meant to be the same character
and the reason why Wonder Woman isn't
fighting in this war is just because she
hasn't been born yet but when this is
all happening apparently Darkseid was
speaking a whole lot they recorded a
bunch of voice over dialogue so I
imagine that that will make it back into
the movie too we don't know exactly what
he was saying just that there was a
bunch of dialogue that they recorded for
it if you've ever watched any of the
animated movies like Justice League
apocalypse war or the other animated
series that have used Darkseid usually
those get pretty close to approximating
Darkseid speech patterns pretty well it
was actually Tony Todd that did the
voice of dark side during Justice League
Apocalypse war Candyman himself he also
did the voice of zoom on the flash in
the early seasons too also side note too big
reminder Darkseid is going to be a big
character in the upcoming New Gods movie
that DC is making based on Tom Kings mr.
miracle comic book but that'll be
completely different from the Justice
League Snyder cut version of Darkseid
the Ray Porter actor who plays dark side
in the Snyder cut said that he hasn't
been contacted by the New Gods people
yet it's a totally different creative
team but it's going to be a couple years
before that movie comes out so they're
probably not going to release any previews
for that for a while if you want to know
what's going on in the New Gods movie
just read Tom Kings mr. miracle run it's
mostly based around mr. miracle a dark
side is just a big character in the
background during most of that but Tom
King himself is actually working on the
script for that so it's going to be super
weird so I can't wait to see what they
do with it
as for what Darkseid actually looks like
inside the Justice League Snyder cut
just because the Zack Snyder himself has
been sharing so many of these scenes and
images I imagine this is pretty close to
what he's actually going to look like in
the cut number two I've seen a lot of
questions about this what Zack Snyder is
actually going to be doing to finish his
version of the
Schneider cut is first to re-edit all
the footage he already shot into a
coherent cut of the movie you probably
heard the reports that they're turning
it into an episodic maxi series
releasing six episodes weekly with act
breaks but the reports also state that
the six episodes would be closer to 40
minutes each so the total run time of
the movie if you marathoned it would
still be just a little over four hours
so that's what people are talking about
when they say that the Snyder cut is
around four hours long but they're
turning it into six different episodes
the theatrical cut was only about two
hours long the dark side actor said he
wasn't sure whether or not all of the
scenes would make it back into the movie
implying that there was a lot of dark
side stuff that he recorded but the two
extra hours worth of movie that they're
adding back in is like a whole other
movie inside the movie so I think it's
safe to assume that pretty much
everything that was cut for all the
different characters and storylines is
coming back in they've also been reports
about what's going on with them filming
additional footage and recording new
dialogue with all the actors people
wondering if Ben Affleck is coming back
to do more Batman because he's getting
super swole like this is what Ben
Affleck looks like right now so whatever
he's been doing during quarantine it has
been doing him some good there's all the
other talk about Henry Cavill officially
coming back as Superman in some upcoming
DC movies the way they're talking about
it is him signing a contract like Mark
Ruffalo's Hulk contract in the MCU where
he crosses over into a bunch of other
movies I just did a video about that
yesterday so I'll link that at the end
of this in number one probably one of
the biggest deleted scenes that we've
learned about is Martian Manhunter
so apparently harry lennix from Man of
Steel was supposed to be a version of
Martian Manhunter in disguise presumably
at some point during Justice League he
would have revealed himself it seems
like Zack Snyder is hyping that he might
wind up making it back into the Snyder
cut so we might actually see a version
of Martian Manhunter show up in that
according to official reports what
Warner Brothers is giving Zack Snyder
money for is to finish editing and
special effects on the footage he
already shot that's the bulk of the
money like re-editing Darkseid into the
movie in a couple different scenes
recording some new dialogue with the
main Justice League actors like Batman
Superman Wonder Woman the flash cyborg
Aquaman Alfred Lois Lane you get the
idea the only thing I don't think we're
going to see is that originally he was
going to kill Batman and I
that was going to happen during the second
movie Batman was going to sacrifice his
life to save everyone and it was meant
to be a parallel for Superman
sacrificing himself to save everyone in
Batman V Superman but like I said before
if you're wondering what was going to
happen in that original version of the
three movie Justice League plan a lot of
that plays out very similarly to Justice
League apocalypse war now that movie is
a little bit different obviously the
animated people are doing their own
thing but some of the plot elements of
that are very similar to Zack Snyder's
plans for his original Justice League
trilogy but if we get any other news
about that or they release any more
teasers or previews of course I'll do a
video about it leave all your requests
in the comments below every one click
here for the Justice League Snyder cut
teaser trailer and click here to learn
all about what's going on with Henry
Cavill coming back as Superman and Man
of Steel in the DC movies thank you so
much for watching everyone stay safe
I'll see you guys tonight!